des jets de pierres survolent la place
de la gare de montbéliard en direction
des crs
la réplique est immédiate de la part des
forces de l'ordre puis très vite la
situation dégénère un jeune lycéen est
blessé à la tête lors d'une altercation
avec les crs selon les services de
secours
son pronostic vital n'est pas engagé
parmi les quelque 300 lycéens sur place
nombreux sont venus manifester
pacifiquement
il déplore les actes de violence de part
et d'autre
en fin de matinée le calme est revenu
les manifestants se sont dispersés
à l'heure actuelle les forces de l'ordre
sont toujours en vigilance
la gare de montbéliard elle est toujours
fermé au public
le trafic est quant à lui interrompu